yo what's up this king combs checking me
out on bootleg cat podcast
yeah bad boy ah
who like cavs show special guest in here
king combs ladies and gentlemen yeah
yeah it was goody congrats on this new
record uh can't stop won't stop good
looking kodak black we outside again me
and kodak black can't stop won't stop go
get that now it's a movie you're telling
me the summer is over i saw you uh
rolling loud you gifted him a bad boy
chain yeah
bad boy chain man shout out kodak he's
part of the family that's my guy you
know he looked out they can't stop won't
stop his song going up so what's the
story of this record was it like his
record first your record first like how
did it come to be yeah first i mean
first it was his we always talked about
like doing music together but like one
day he just sent it to me
like through the dm he was like yo i
need a song to sing and i was like i bet
you sent him my number
and he sent it through and i just hopped
on it that day so he had already did the
can't stop both stop bad boy [ __ ] and
all that so it was already like bro yeah
i need to get i need to tap in he said
he already had that in mind i'll let him
tell the story exactly how he came about
but
yeah that's crazy
so when y'all do this video and y'all
bust out the vintage
you know
mace ditty [ __ ]
gear whose idea was that that was my
idea right there because i always loved
him jerseys yeah i was trying to think
of how we could do the video crazy and
he already had most of the concept of
how we should do like the crush on you
right like remake because that was like
a no-brainer like i agree with that too
so i was just like yo
you gotta have the jerseys to match the
floor like yeah fire
so yeah does your dad have to green
light all of this stuff
no no no like if you're like yo pops
we're going to redo a classic video
do we do you have the jersey guy still
not me of course
like
i've been brought back to jersey like
okay 2018 i brought back the jerseys but
nah usually i'll just play him the song
if he ain't like it
then it would be a different situation i
think it's your best record you think so
yes i'm not a good looking man because i
heard the record i was like
oh this is easy to play this is a great
record yeah i think it's i think it's i
think it's a a
great song man thanks so much yeah i
love that song it's really one of my
favorite songs sounds like you're
getting like real comfortable too like
you're comfortable in your own skin i
feel like you know when you first came
out like you look so much like your dad
your king combs yeah you know what i'm
saying i feel like you're finally really
kind of getting in your bag as an artist
good looking you feel like that no yeah
i definitely do it's been like a few
years now so i got to really get
comfortable in my own space be in the
studio more
do you like you shook like the the the
shadow of your pops because i feel like
you you're kind of getting there right i
feel like you know that that definitely
is off i feel like time will tell you
know it's a big legacy i'm not really
trying to shake nothing that's my pops
no of course i just mean in terms of
like you know i feel like when people
come from like a family like you know of
[ __ ] hip-hop royalty yeah
you can't help but like
people automatically will compare you to
your dad you know what i'm saying yeah
for sure but i feel like you know you
put you've put out enough dope records
to you know really stand on your own if
you needed to oh yeah good looking and
that's how i feel i feel like
really i gotta just put in the work and
the workers just speak for itself right
and that's what i really want the most i
don't want to have it handed to me i
want the people to you know choose and i
feel like with this song can't stop
won't stop
we outside it's lit so uh yo you were in
miami uh for rolling loud which was
crazy and i know you were at the crib on
star island the legendary star island
star island man pull up the starling if
you're in miami i don't know if it's
that easy
just call me dm me you gotta look up you
probably gotta look a certain way right
yeah
do people pull up on jet skis to the
back of the house
yeah sometimes you know it'd be a lot of
tour boats like pulling up yo
diddy diddy sometimes they think of my
pops i'll be walking like yo
that shit's crazy you gotta like i mean
for people who don't know like in miami
like uh
it's like open water so like the
backyards are just like obviously
there's a backyard but then there's like
the ocean and your boat's there and all
that [ __ ] so people could really just
like you know be on some real paparazzi
weirdo [ __ ] if they wanted to for sure
and it's a full time like tour boat that
comes like every
every day same time 10 minutes you're
like that's diddy's house 35 minutes oh
there they go right there i'll just be
in the back
that's so strong
it's cool though like i feel like it's
all love it would be different if they
was like don't hate like his love is
what like our family a legacy worked for
and
yeah yeah i saw i just rewatched the uh
can't stop won't stop documentary
because it just got put on netflix it's
been out for a while but it just got put
on netflix so i watched it a couple of
weeks ago
which was a crazy uh you know that
reunion show
yeah were you there yeah i was dead uh i
came out like in the tour like that was
like my first time really like showing
the world i was doing music that's crazy
so that was an important
couple of days for you as well yeah that
tour was crazy that was crazy that that
the um
the show was on the barclays yeah they
did it back-to-back days right yeah then
yeah they did back-to-back days then we
actually did a world tour no i remember
the tour was right after but the barclay
[ __ ] was like the yeah the barclays was
crazy that was the best show i've ever
been to yeah it was crazy too because
like watching the show and like
your your dad's like kind of
i know the first show didn't start off
the way he had liked and it was kind of
chaotic and then the second show was
like
everything was like perfect but like
him being such a hard worker and like a
perfectionist it's almost like
alien-like
we don't see many people who have that
kind of drive that kind of determination
that kind of
will for success
that has to rub off on you too right i
mean obviously you came up you know in a
very nice situation but like it feels
like you got a little bit of that unit
as well right yeah like with my pops he
really like instills that in us you know
working hard and if you have a dream you
know following your dreams so full it's
like don't be capping saying you want to
do something and not putting in the work
so
yeah like when we in the crib
it'd be serious like if we if it's work
time it's work time because you know he
working all day so he can't just be
working and we playing around like
you know we may be serious a full family
like legacy have you ever played him a
record and he had been like hell no
yeah yeah for sure you can't put that
[ __ ] out he definitely hit stuff and be
like nah nah
you know i got the freedom to put it out
like he was like if you want to do it
like you know you're a grown man but
that's not it and usually you know i
listen to him and we we always
you know have
like trust in each other but you know
sometimes i do my own thing you though
hey we got to stop the interview real
quick tell you about our good folks at
odd socks uh listen go to
oddssocksofficial.com they're presenting
sponsor of the bootleg kit podcast when
you go on there use the promo code
bootleg cab all one word together
bootleg kev
and you're going to get 20 off your
entire odd socks order they get all the
crazy licenses my g they got the basics
they got the twizzlers the warhead
underwear how about these these are
godfather draws you know i'm saying
shout out to the bootleg kev socks
we're gonna be dropping some merch
and if you buy the merch you get free
socks that's coming shortly uh but yo
oddssoxoficial.com
the most comfortable socks in the world
the craziest licenses they got some big
ones coming down the pipeline i can't
talk about but they just did drop
doritos and uh
[ __ ] cheetos and all that good [ __ ]
uh so listen go to oddssoxofficial.com
use the promo code bootleg cap save 20
off today go do that let's get back to
the interview can you see yourself one
day like running bad boy
yeah for sure
definitely if you're running backwards a
new chef in town man
let's say right now you're you're
obviously your dad was putting out
albums while running a label
um
if you're running the label right now
who's the up-and-coming artist that
you're you're a fan of that you would
sign hypothetically
if i'm running the label right now
i'll probably go with my man cod cash
okay cyn cod cash going crazy got fleek
ghosts nico the whole gang
these your friends yeah okay okay of
course there
[Laughter]
yeah yeah he's like i got a shot
but besides
how about someone who you've never met
that you're just a fan of someone who i
never met it feels like you're probably
tapped in with the young [ __ ] like
yeah yeah i mean
i would say like
the young new york crowd the young bronx
like
around there yeah the bronx [ __ ] is
going up yeah ross smith is fired rock
smith is hard yeah yeah shout out to the
bronx shout out the whole the whole
drill [ __ ] is like
it's crazy yeah and uh one of them go up
but now i feel like it's a lot of
artists it's a couple artists i know
that we got that
that's fine i think people forget that
machine gun kelly's on bad boy
in fact right like he just headlined
lollapalooza and just headlined his own
arena tour biggest that's my guy right
there that's what i'm saying he's like
mgk he's like arguably the biggest rock
star in the world
and crazy by the way
it's it's he's on bad boy i'm bad boy
listen bad boy is making a comeback
we're just letting y'all know but the
other thing is i'm not sure it ever went
anywhere because people forget machine
gun kelly's on back yeah never went
nowhere french is on bad boy french i
mean bad boy always been you're on bad
boy yeah i'm on bad boy but
i just had to let them know so now you
know we got kodak with us kodak gang
that's really the honest i would sign
kodak kodak it's hard so you gift him
the chain
do we do we talk to pops and say hey
let's get him out of his deal let's
bring him to bad boy yeah you know he's
kind of kind of talking about that but
you know yeah we figured that out
have you ever had sniper gang cymb have
you ever wanted a feature
and then just called your dad because
they no one's going to tell your dad no
no no no
would you say if i call something like
let's say you want a feature right but
like maybe you don't know the artist
do you have your pops make the call
nah but you never know sometimes you
might have to use that in a bag of
tricks i got it in there just in case i
need to pull it out but i i didn't do it
yet here it is have you um
picked up any party talents from your
father because your father is obviously
a legendary
i mean we're talking about probably the
most legendary parties in rap history up
there you know what i'm saying facts
when you're with your homies
you know what i'm saying and you got the
shorts right now we got the best parties
me and my brother
you know just glow i'm brother justin we
got the best parties right now you gotta
come i'm sorry i didn't give you an
invite before this well i heard yeah
because i heard like that we hung out in
miami and i guess the night before you
barely slept yeah yeah now he was up the
whole time i am he was going up i was by
myself out there me and my brothers get
together it's kind of different you guys
are different huh yeah yeah we got the
best parties you get pointers from uh
from your pops like a dad uh we really
just been watching
he really don't got to say nothing he
don't give me advice on too much it
really like it's something we've been
it's just like a giving that we know you
know yeah and most of the stuff you know
he expects us to know sometimes by
asking something he's like yo you know
come on man you've seen me all this
stuff right
um are you working on an album right now
yeah because obviously the single's
going crazy yeah i'm working on my debut
album it's about to come out man the
singer's out right now so what was the
last body of work was that just a
mixtape yes okay that was a mixtape
debut album it's gonna be called can
stop one stop the actual album no no no
no the title i'm not for sure i got like
two titles i'm choosing a
going off of that but i can't stop don't
stop at the single right now i like it
who else is on the project do you know
yet are you just working yeah i got a
couple a couple on there we got
sway lee swailey okay uh shout out to
fab going up
that's crazy
yeah i think uh you know with a record
like this can't stop won't stop one
having kodak on the record obviously
always helps but
the fact that he reached out to you
and he was like aware like yo this is
like
the hook is so like if you didn't tell
me that he it was his record first i
would have been like yo this had to have
been your idea
honestly when he said to me i'm like yo
like did i tell him i wanted to do this
yeah this is hard right yeah it was a
perfect the perfect joint and he's
really like a genius like how he put it
together like even down like to the
video and
and all that like he was smart with the
certain things that he said that we
should do and that made it just go viral
100 man um besides your dad who's like a
big homie in the rap game that you look
to for like advice or
you know when it comes to like
if you need to go to somebody for maybe
your dad's busy closing a billion dollar
deal or something yeah
i would say hov
before i dropped this home he had to
talk and
that inspired me a lot so jd yeah
i just love how you just threw that out
there like yeah i hope
thanks
what did the talk entail personally you
said what what was the talk about
talk was definitely worth the money now
they was like yo would you take the talk
everybody it was definitely worth it he
was just saying you know like
to believe in yourself and
just always like
follow like what's in your heart
like not what no one else is saying or
anything just do what's in your heart so
your advice would be
say no to the 500 grand and take the
dinner with hove definitely take the
dinner with hope
do you think so for sure was this over
the phone or in person it was in person
that's so fire yeah
like do you like call it like jay-z theo
or something is he like your uncle kind
of low-key
you got some [ __ ] powerful uncles
jesus
you got to get hover on you got to bring
him like he's on the new calendar album
so you got to get him on your album that
would be crazy he's on the khalid album
i hope you see this i need a verse
no i'm gonna get that one today we're
gonna get that um what's your writing
process like do you write like on your
phone are you writing as you rap because
you know some people just punch in like
how are you like when you're writing
your [ __ ] how do you usually go about
doing that um sometimes it's different i
usually just like to
put on the beat and just like go off of
instinct just vibe
on whatever i feel sometimes like if
it's a serious song i might have to sit
there and write it like to the can't
stop won't stop i was like hold on this
is hitting a little hard i might have to
think about what i'm about to say yeah
before i just go and just freestyle so
sometimes you'll freestyle though yeah i
mean sometimes
right
what up we got to stop the interview
real quick um to tell you about our good
folks at blue chew don't forget man
right now you get a whole month of blue
chew
for free
that's right fellas you're dealing with
that erectile dysfunction maybe you're
under some stress some anxiety maybe
your man ain't working the way it's
supposed to
listen blue chew got you same active
ingredients as viagra and cialis uh but
it goes straight to your doorstep in
discreet packaging
no doctor's appointments where you got
to go show up to the doctor's office and
have some awkward conversation about why
you're cocking up the bar bud no sir all
online go to bluechu.com use the promo
code bootleg
that's bluechu.com
promo code
bootleg use the promo code for me it
helps us out all right go do that and
tell me how your dick is i'll take dm
just don't send me a picture of it
because that will get you black bud are
you old enough to go to the strip club
yet
yeah okay
what's your go-to in
miami booby trap the booby trap booby
trap is it good eleven
eleven is five they give you the
massages i went to 11 for the first time
last week
oh what it was it might have surpassed
tootsies for me
yeah cause i love seven eleven is five i
love tootsies because they got that
fried lobster tail with the seafood rice
yeah lemon was different i felt like i
was in it so yeah i really just got into
eating at the strip club i never was
like i never even really knew about that
i ordered some wings one time i was
hungry i was like wait i'm about to be
in here all day and there's a place
called food in here oh yeah there's a
place called having shrimp yeah
you said lobster fried rice uh a fried
lobster tail with shrimp fried rice at
tootsies is amazing but i went to taboo
in miami which is i guess tori owns
artifact
no it's it's a fried lobster tail with
seafood rice it was like a lobster tail
on top
but taboo in miami
they got some they got a chef in that
[ __ ] oh my god
i'm like dog i just eat here all day
yeah do they do uber eats bring it to
the hotel yeah no because i used to be
young just running in the clubs like you
know kind of sneaking through but now i
could really be in there like
figure out what's going on they used to
be like yo let's get him into the back
door yeah back door hide behind the
camera i'm like yo oh yeah cause you
were doing like clubs and [ __ ] when you
were
before you were able to get in yeah like
19. yeah
how would that work
because you were like hosting it didn't
matter never really say nothing because
you know my brothers was always yeah
older than me so
um it would work out that's big man uh
vegas and vegas they was tripping but
shout out vegas because i'm coming out
there this saturday we performing can't
stop won't stop for the first time
well not the first time but first time
on the west coast where are you uh going
to be at in vegas um i think the palms
pool party the palms is a movie yes
that's back oh yeah yeah you weren't old
enough but it was that pumps used to be
that hot [ __ ] in vegas bro back in the
day it was like the hottest [ __ ] in base
was the poems
then it's i don't know what happened
y'all remember when the palms was lit
like raining in the 90s or something oh
jesus don't age me that much [ __ ]
now like 2008 2009 2007 2010 like the
palms was [ __ ] popping that's like
when uh paulie d and [ __ ] was dj is he
he probably is still djing like that
jersey shore days oh yeah yeah probably
it was a wild time he was out there with
him dj no no no no i would just i lived
i lived in vegas at the time i lived
there so they them fools are hosting
everything yes um yeah yo record's going
up
your pops got a record going crazy
father and son both on the on the rhythm
chart right now we got to move on yeah
we going up on the charts man you see
what's going on yeah for sure are you
gonna have him
yeah yeah he might have to have a
one two one two verse real quick um
what's it like getting scolded by diddy
he'd be on your head is it crazy because
you know i've seen video
of him like yo fix your [ __ ] energy
fix your [ __ ] energy and then come
back go for a [ __ ] walk come back i
don't like your [ __ ] energy sometimes
you should be like yo wait yo what's up
and then there's that video recently
that's my pop so it's like you know we
sit behind the desk you know the famous
video where he's like i need more and
he's like
that every time i watch definitely gonna
get you motivated every time i watch
that [ __ ] i want to go outside and just
make a [ __ ] trillion dollars it
usually doesn't work out you know what
i'm saying but you know
but no he's definitely gonna he
definitely gets you motivated whenever i
get those scolding lessons or like
you try to put me on game and that is
serious
i come out of that a new man i feel like
every time that's dope man uh do you
have a timetable for when you want to
drop your project or is it just
definitely before this year is over
right there's another single dropping
before the summer's over we're not
letting up let's go man can't stop we
won't stop so i'm gonna stop there it is
go get the single go watch the video
album coming soon
anything else go drink i'm coming soon
go drink uh
deleon do not do bacardi aqua hydrate
wave juice you had the wave juice right
uh-huh oh man what's that yeah i get the
wave juice what is that nina wave juice
we got to come it's my keto friendly
it's my soda is this your blue bottle do
you have not this one oh
yeah
that's not your dad's water that's not
your dad's water though it's about to be
yeah what's up with aqua hydrate man
look i'm [ __ ] still going i'm
violating this about that we're gonna
water though this this is like a new
brand that's coming soon we can't speak
too much on it yet but
your dad's water right there new brand
i'm gonna let him speak on that but
it's something that we're working on
sirocco i like what else is uh what else
are we plugging anything else we want to
plug for you leave what else are we
plugging right now man shout out my boy
we outside bootleg kev king combs we're
going up i love everybody that's rocking
with the new song with me and kodak
shout out to y'all
it's love can't stop won't stop dancing
stop won't stop go play that you'll be
playing on the radio i'm playing right
now playing right now man ah shout out
kodak black you already know what it is
bad boy